oh my god oh [ __ ] Oh oh hey what's going
on guys from first we feast the top ones
the show with hot questions and even
hotter wings and today I'm joined in
studio by Machine Gun Kelly what's going
on man up dude do you know how the show
works yes how do you think it works
stuff a bunch of chicken wings in their
mouth and [ __ ] for three days that's 90%
of it there are 10 chicken wings sir 10
sauces 10 questions as we go further
along in the interview the wings get
hotter the questions get hotter so hot
in fact that you might just need to bail
so you just say lace-up and then you
don't have to eat any more wings then we
just go straight to the hottest question
and ask you the hottest question okay
all right if you make it all the way
through we'll give you 30 uninterrupted
seconds to plug it up do you want if you
tap out I take half of your plug okay
all right does that sound good to you no
because I don't do spicy food I've never
ate like a spicy hot wing in my life but
I'm here so [ __ ] but first wing
should be no problem first question
should be no problem are you ready all
right Machine Gun Kelly here your hot
ones
those first sauce is just Texas Pete hot
sauce you would see it on every
restaurant and it every breakfast spot
and then your first question used to
work at Chipotle right there are two
types of employees at Chipotle okay
there are the ones who when they're
scooping ingredients sort of ride the
bin and give you a bountiful portion
then there are some that shake the spoon
up yeah and you see pieces of chicken
breasts falling off the spoon are you
the one who rides the bin are you one of
those cowards who shakes the spoon I'll
tell you one thing
I [ __ ] hate those spoon shakers Oh
always a man of the people and I was
always like [ __ ] the system this isn't
my chicken two scoops even I'll give you
double [ __ ] bin for the place just
cuz I don't give a [ __ ] alright number
two a little hot sauce no big deal right
now
alright this is the you can't echo those
until this up in Europe there's this all
you [ __ ] got hot sauce this is this
is what I've been missing out on the
whole time yeah this isn't [ __ ] it's
easy to say that after the third wing
okay we'll see how it goes
but as somebody who doesn't eat wings
maybe you shouldn't have been so scared
of them to begin yeah yeah you're right
all right that's an awakening for
Machine Gun Kelly over here you ready
for number four yeah all right so this
is a lot ease I don't not fill in the
stomach fill feeling the yellow color a
little intimidated by it or what right
when you start talking is when you start
feeling normally start talking [ __ ]
so this one actually has pain in the
title pain is good because it's dis
style look at this dude's face dude that
is what happens ha ha
thank you the giantest of shits that
might be though that might be a painful
[ __ ] right yeah come on Tony yeah yo
come on
good my guess is that near 25 years on
this planet you've had to deal with some
severe hangovers and your life is not
like mine like you can't just nurse 64
ounces of Gatorade smoke a little weed
and watch Netflix and just sort of rest
it off so it leads me to believe that
you have to have some sort of ritual or
some sort of hangover cure that you use
that's gonna question when I like come
it like kind of like relieves like
everything shakes that I just got clean
yeah if I like [ __ ] like take a shower
throw up [ __ ] and then take a shower
again like get back to school back yeah
well you know or if I have to you know
do it myself you know yeah if there's no
girls or not how does it get it done or
I'll [ __ ] a peach or something have you
ever [ __ ] something
I [ __ ] um I want to say a watermelon
in watermelon that's like a safe bag I
guess I mean it's you know so cold so
now this one is paying 100 percent hot
sauce is what it's called we also have a
guy no no kids screaming yeah this is
where it starts to turn
holy fit oh right
oh [ __ ] dog okay I don't think you can
make it as long as you have in this
industry without making a few enemies
and I wonder [ __ ] what gets you kicked
out of the MGK crew like what makes you
close the window on a person and paint
it shut well one if you're my friend I'm
never kicking out but if you're all my
tour bus and you're if this is the head
deciding if you kick off my tour bus
come up to me and tell me if I can take
a shot again oh come up to me and ask
why I'm not smiling again because I bet
I'll kick you the [ __ ] out cuz [ __ ] you
like I just got off [ __ ] stage we
been on for an hour and a half I had
been a whole [ __ ] time my neck hurts
my body hurts
I'm bleeding cuz someone scratched me or
I fell off a cage or something
maybe I want like 30 minutes of [ __ ]
downtime given I do this every single
night and even though this is the first
night for you I just did this for the
other [ __ ] nights I'm hungry I'm
horny and you're like why aren't you
smiling
I don't know cuz I maybe if I'm smile at
the [ __ ] big dumbass smile on my
[ __ ] face on the tour bus you'd be
like you look like a [ __ ] pedophile I
don't not try to come around you and you
know what's crazy I am [ __ ] crazy and
I will [ __ ] go crazy but don't [ __ ]
tell me to go crazy because you know
what I want to do when you tell me to go
crazy now I want to not go [ __ ] crazy
cuz you know what I'm not I'm not a
[ __ ] puppet you're on my [ __ ]
parents you're not my [ __ ] boss you
know what I'm saying alright
you can't teach me [ __ ] about this party
[ __ ] I don't need your [ __ ] help you
know what I mean everybody just get off
em GK's back goddamn ready for this next
one how you feeling if you feel nice to
see this is one death see that's when
the death is right and the glares
original death sauce like what a [ __ ]
name yeah [ __ ] taste anything I felt
like I could [ __ ] do algebra right
now what do you got alright alright well
it's a free beep hey so this so did he's
sort of like white party Hamptons
lifestyle I'm pretty far removed from
East Cleveland yeah and I wonder what
was that first like ultra luxe decadent
opulent window into Diddy's world
alright do you want some come to Vegas
and when did he says come to Vegas you
come running right I mean when you're
broke as [ __ ]
in your managers mom's basement when
you're hopped up all Viking if I'm a car
accident and you're thinking about your
life weights unless you're like holy
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] am I gonna do I'm
working at Chipotle
yeah you get I would get on the plane
right yeah so get there he has the
biggest suite and the palms there's
waterfalls on his room there's a [ __ ]
River in his room he's like alright
we're gonna go to work we're gonna go
out this is this always said he said
we're gonna go out I'm like I'm 20 years
old
yep UK shut the [ __ ] up don't worry
about let's go the [ __ ] club so we go to
club getting every single club this
[ __ ] it's New Years Eve some
other [ __ ] did he takes me to nine
[ __ ] clubs in one night nine [ __ ]
clubs this is not for this I mean four
is crazy right so this is nine [ __ ]
club 30 bottles a spot that's I mean a
table 30 times nine is what 270 270 so
207 bottles easy I don't know where
those wins confetti everywhere women
everywhere get to okay nine spots over
I'm like [ __ ] I'm poop man you know I
mean like peace out yeah going to sleep
hotel we're not going to focus sleep and
this faster for two [ __ ] days and I
[ __ ] see them sleep in one [ __ ]
time we're getting the Greek yeah just
like that was that might as well been a
documentary this [ __ ] this is
called Dave's temporary and sanity hot
sauce this one makes multiple
appearances so the next one's Dave's in
sand and this is the one they say if
you're pregnant don't yeah this is like
this is the part of the show where we
probably should have made you sign a
waiver but okay it's okay
damn right a little bit
you're you know oh [ __ ] okay
we get the rest of the wing within them
you got a lot of tabs man you can handle
some pain right so you're hosting a WWE
event is that later this month yeah if
you were a professional wrestler would
your persona be like the Machine Gun
Kelly Wilde Boyd thing or would it be
different you think maybe I'd be like a
professor and just kick ass in a suit
you know what I throw them on the
[ __ ] ground
my [ __ ] sit on them and I'd opened my
[ __ ] textbook and read to the people
then the ultimate flat you [ __ ] sit
there while I [ __ ] read this book in
you know while I teach the topography of
South America right now you starting to
get there man this is uncharted
territory just Anthony Rizzo holy [ __ ]
dude this is so hot I'm like every time
I breathe it's increasingly totter
Norley so this is Dave's insanity hot
sauce thirty-six times hotter than a
jalapeno okay
whoa oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] damn dog oh [ __ ]
dude whoa whoa
like what kind of [ __ ] psychopath
would just put on aha with my nose I
[ __ ] ah ah dude damn and what the
wrong half man how do you how do you
keep like the boardroom [ __ ] you
know like the label politics separate
from who you are you know if you try to
be like this pop if you're being this
punk rock figure do you have to
constantly turn [ __ ] down you have to
yeah about money you know I realize a
stupid one like you do all that to keep
your authenticity and then you do
something like anything somebody take a
movie role and you have to change your
hair for a movie role right right I like
in in just doing something as simple as
like your hair someone's like oh you
[ __ ] sellout man okay you know I mean
and your psyche I've done all this [ __ ]
to be so authentic
you're [ __ ] what good what do you do
what do you [ __ ] do when it's this
spicy what do you do you just thought by
this Oklahoma you find here's the deal
cuz I'll tell you why I said call me
does you're the cop I get hurt yeah like
I'm sweaty and put the head the head
does your head you got something else
going on bro
so as Chris suggested we put a fresh dab
on this one dude so this is mad dog 357
it's almost I don't want to psych you
out but it's almost twice as hot as what
we just need okay no I don't want for my
dad well then I think that's mine I
think what I got is fine right there
you're not gonna or this will be my
third time all right nothing but um but
be careful that yeah this is gonna be
this is not gonna be fun for the
internet for the internet bro for the
Internet
oh my god oh [ __ ]
oh-oh-oh I'm GK are you in love oh oh
you aren't [ __ ] dude [ __ ] do that [ __ ]
[ __ ] hurts
are you in love MGK I'm giving love a
chance you've given love a chance
how'd you an amber me how does how does
MDK me to Amber Rose not just Sam giving
love each other to me you know it
doesn't mean that you're giving love a
chance no no no no give me a love a
chance I'm saying I want you to beat the
over here thinking I'm you know I'm like
you know struggling no I got I'm saying
yeah I want you telling what somebody w
[ __ ] know we've been hanging out all
morning man
I feel like I know who you are I think
we've got it all these ways and oh god
it's so hard yeah yeah don't you Sonny
why are you sending so calm because I'm
kind of like um I'm tough as [ __ ] when
it comes to wings I'm gonna put see a
pretty much everything else but wings I
[ __ ] got what was the question
I just second question how'd you meet
Amber Rose how didn't Machine Gun Kelly
meet Amber Rose I was at the MTV Movie
Awards I dressed like a homeless person
but then how do you end up getting her
attention if you're dressed like a
homeless person dog you tell me I have
no [ __ ] idea like what would you say
like well I didn't say anything I just
said something to you know her she she
tells she told somebody to come tap me
and that was an awesome experience I
can't imagine I don't live life on that
level nobody's ever said like hey Amber
Rose was to talk to you to me that was
an exciting thing there wasn't
yeah you're happy you're happy are you
happier now than you were six weeks ago
[Music]
yes yes yeah yeah definitely
all right Cheers well well you earned
your [ __ ] plug man battle through my
guy 30 seconds talk about the new music
talk about the upcoming album talk about
the movies talk about I don't give a
[ __ ] when you talk about 30 seconds all
yours bro go ahead right into the camera
it's been three years since my first
album this is my sophomore album coming
in this summer I put my heart and soul
into it I revealed a lot about myself in
it I told the story that MuNet that
needed to be told that I haven't touched
on yet in my life and you know if you
don't like this one then you have no
soul go [ __ ] yourself go [ __ ] yourself
[Music]
you